foreign
on camera with the clothes on
you knock out your dick out no no no
it's the first time for everything yeah
to be fair I've just been using it as
well I heard yeah Rebecca Moore
do you know Rebecca Moore that's her
okay right okay and this is your this
was today's episode mate that was
literally about an hour ago really so
I've gone from looking at her and having
a lick me bum like a stamp to looking at
you sorry Beauty and the Beast
she's the beast
so you are pretty much every single day
you're shooting something yeah and I
reckon it's about six and a half
thousand scenes is that a record I I
read somewhere you're like the most like
the guy who shot the most scenes in
terms of being able to trace it all yeah
because there's a lot on IMDb yeah and
stuff like that and obviously on
browsers alone yeah because I've been
contracted with them for 15 years so
that's a lot of bums vaginas and mouths
that I've seen and obviously some of
them scenes got taken down for various
reasons but yeah there's a there's about
15 1600 just on browsers then there's
Digital Playground Reality Kings and
some of the
we're just going naturally but for those
who don't know this is Kieran Lee one of
the biggest known porn stars in history
um you know like I said you hold the
record you're well known because you had
your cop insured for a million grade by
your company browsers you work very
closely with and
um take us through today right earlier a
day you turn up tell me how it goes
literally today I've woke up I've text
you my excuses to get here and then I
was like I have to shoot Rebecca because
Becca is only in town for so many days
and so I was like I have to shoot with
her because we're doing a Content trade
so you do one for yours yeah yeah yes we
we both keep it and we both sell it on
our on our platform like only fans and
so we both go away and we both make
money from it and for me now doing the
content trades I just kind of work with
the girls that I really enjoy working
with you know no stress no drama what
what what what is it like as a performer
that you're looking at going good versus
bad like what are the things that you
don't want to have to deal with see for
me I just don't want to deal with divas
and drama you know I mean like you'll
get some of the most beautiful girls and
they know it and it's like don't do this
don't do that that like you know don't
don't be [__] like you know drawing
Stills and it's like listen you're a guy
you have to keep the blood flowing down
below and things like that and some
girls are a bit like
and I get it it is our job to keep our
dick hard but sometimes you know a
little bit of help just edging away and
things like that can be a nightmare so
an attitude yeah yeah and it can be a
big turn off you know what I mean and
that for me I'm like I I don't really
need to be doing that especially at my
stage in my career now before I just
used to Smiling going okay no problem
now I'm like oh yeah because in the
industry from everything I've been
researching yeah you're known as kind of
like Mr Nice Guy the women really like
working with you you've got a great
reputation amongst the ladies yeah in in
a sense of like not in a sexual sense
obviously but it as a as a person they
like you does that is that a is that a
deliberate thing that you've sort of
always tried to be or has there has
there been times where you've when a
girl's giving you [__] and you've just
been like enough of that yeah there is I
think they're just like my dad bought
um no there's been one or two girls who
are up and like I I'm like really
pushing me to a limit and I I said one
time there was a a young lady that had
worked with numerous times before and
we're doing an anal scene and she's
pooped on me once she's pooped on me
twice and then the third time I'm sat
and she's in English performer she sat
eating a bag of cheese and onion crisp
so you'll you'll understand that it's
not smelling the best already she's
telling her she's had a curry the night
before and I'm thinking I'm doing her up
the [__]
this is going to be a long day and so
anyway I've I've put it in I've pulled
out and
it just got it looked like I dip my dick
in Nutella I have just gone right you
can have that back and I just flicked it
her face and walked off and that was it
that's probably not my most devourish
moment I've ever had on set just because
I'm thinking a bit of respect you know
I'm throwing balls deep in your bum okay
so for those who don't understand though
like this is a process that she should
have been like performers for for women
who do innocent the night before I'm
assuming they have to do stuff yeah yeah
so a lot of the girls they stop eating
at like six seven o'clock at night
they'll clean out their bum they won't
eat anything you know no coffee or
anything in the morning then before
they're scene they'll just check the bum
again clean it out and if it's a long
day these girls are you know they're on
set they're not eating anything so they
they maybe have a you know a few gummy
bears and things like that because it's
clear and it goes straight through
but yeah no they this summer girls are
very very professional like you could
you could eat the dinner off the bottom
yeah
I love it what a wildlife you [__]
have Jesus and you're actually well
known to be good at anal yeah the
American Girls Love me love a bit of
foreskin and so I don't know it feels it
feels better for them I think it's like
the little sleeve foreign
how quickly from entering the door are
you inside her so me and Becca we've
shot many times and like she's
unbelievable she makes any man feel like
a king and so we have this running thing
like she does a lot of like role play
stuff you know secretary and like Bex
this is me and you we just [__] so
literally she texts me and said right
I'm heading up she walks through the
door
and she just dropped to her knees
straight away straight at it and then we
just everything was all set up ready to
go 35 minutes
shot me Bolt
right is is a baby work and then we just
had a chat how you been what you been up
to
that is the the porn world you can go
from being balls deep in a 30 40 minutes
ago to then ask him do you have a nice
Christmas what what else have you been
up to you're going away this year
there's an interesting Dynamic with you
when I was looking into your character I
was like you on the one hand you're this
Lads lad who's a you know go to the
match and support your team have a pain
but then you're living like in L.A you
like a bit of ball talks you look after
yourself I love that yeah you know but
like and is that a bit of a conflicted
thing like because when when I go back
to Newcastle even living in London
sometimes I feel like like these are
this is the real me yeah yeah you know
and the version of me in London is this
sort of sanitized version
yeah do you ever feel a bit like that oh
100 like but the thing is I always look
at this you know I've always been a
Shepherd not a sheep and I've always
like you know what my Missy said why
don't you try Botox yeah why not and I
did it I like the look of it yeah I'll
do it all my mates are brickies joining
his electricity I'll go back up I get
absolutely rinse I've been to Turkey
I've got my hair done in Turkey the
first thing I've done you know in La
everyone's oh man that looks so good and
then I go back to Derby and they're like
what the [__] are you doing and they're
pulling at your hair I get the receipt
it looks [__] and but I love that
because it keeps you grounded [__]
road and I can't like I've met so many
people out in L.A and like
I never get Star Struck or anything
listen for me you you eat bleed [__] and
piss the same and that's how I've always
looked at life and the only time that
I've ever kind of got a bit Starstruck
is I've got obviously I'm open book I've
got a little boy and my son plays for
the Juventus Academy wow yeah he's a
good good little player he loves the
black and white you know and uh I'm
looking I'm going his manager looks
familiar
and I'm looking over Alessandra del
Piero wow it's not a bad coach is it one
of the best ever yeah ah dopiera I mean
it's really hard to tell your son what's
what in the football and sense when he's
listening to Del Piero and then and then
trying to watch Derby this is a real
team yeah yeah come on I've got to admit
I have kind of lost him a little bit to
Chelsea okay it kills me his favorite
player is Mason Mount all right yeah in
terms of being a dad in the porn
industry
um how hard is that because if there's
one thing I've learned about porn stars
and watching loads of these interviews
before this it's like is how they
struggle to be accepted by Regular
People yeah and then you're like
interacting with I'm assuming your son
will have mated School uh you know how
do you do that I'll be really honest I
never wanted children because of my
profession I just thought it's it's not
right it you know I just thought not
that it's not right I just thought I
don't want my son growing up to be
bullied and like you know oh your dad's
this and your dad does that and I just
didn't really ever want to put it you
know my child in that position and I was
really against it and then me and my
wife she you know she got pregnant and
she lost it but it was a bit of a you
know I'm like oh whoa you know I nearly
I nearly was a dad I really like that
feeling and then she got pregnant again
I was like and I had I had my son and
and that was it and I was like you know
what
people just have to accept it and I I'm
gonna have to have that chat with him
when he's older and there's a chat that
I'm terrified that's that's the one chat
that I am gonna be
petrified did it that's going to be the
hardest moment I think of anything of my
life I respect that just because it's
like especially with today's you know
generation it's like everything's on the
internet you know it's not like you're
in the schoolyard and and having a you
know oh you does this and you have a bit
of a dust up
over here it's more mentally it's like
online it's texian and cyber bullying
and things like that and that is a big
worry that I have
but then on the other hand I think you
know I'm not doing any harm uh you know
my my I've got three children
and they have the best life you know the
the go to a private school they you know
they don't want for anything but I also
teach them the values you know like now
like my little boy he has to do his room
for his pocket when you know like the
old old kind of values and and the thing
that I've always stuck to now and I
think is it a dying it's chivalry I
don't think enough guys you know do
things for like ladies so my little boy
obviously he has his sister if his
sister's cold he knows
give her the jacket you don't ever play
fight with your sister that's my biggest
rule you never lay a hand on a woman
that I really don't agree with and so
it's little things like that and it'd be
quite interesting obviously doing what I
do
because people will look here and go
he's a porn star he's disrespecting
women all the time he's he's choking him
in a scene or slapping them or you know
doing whatever
that's not that's currently the persona
it's not caring the father do you know
what I mean it's there's two different
lives and it's very hard for people to
get their head around now
yeah I think you guys must suffer from a
lot of discrimination
um yeah it must be bad I heard one
female porn star compare it to being a
pedal she said I get treas if I'm I'm
literally molesting people or whatever
yeah whereas I'm literally just with
consenting adults doing a job that it's
the dirty little secret of the internet
that happens to be the biggest thing on
the internet yeah it's it's and it just
kind of shows the hypocrisy of the world
we're living in when everyone condemns
these people and yet everyone watches
them if you look at YouTube views and
then look at porn views there's no
comparison like I watch I've seen one of
your videos because I went and had a
look I went what's the biggest viewed
video on this website that has your name
in it it's like 50 million views like I
don't have a single video that's got 50
million views you know what I'm saying
like the crazy thing if you look on like
like a PornHub ranking it shows you how
many video views that you have had of
like all time and I think mine is a 1.8
billion views there you go yeah that's
top and like that's like it's insane
yeah and it is it is funny that people
will will do that and going into this uh
Prejudice and the way people talk to you
you said it was worse than even like
what have you experienced that made you
feel that way at one time it was you
know I helped out like a family just
getting tickets for a a football game
and I the the people that I knew that
got the tickets only knew me through my
profession and they got them the tickets
and they had the best day ever they you
know the kid had the best day ever
and then afterwards I got an email
saying thanks so much for sorting the
tickets but we'd appreciate if you
didn't mention that we got them from you
as we don't want to be associated with
your kind
of like
hang on
what what's what is my kind yeah the
kind that I stayed up all night to get
you the tickets to make sure that you
guys could have the best day possible
and it wasn't just a normal ticket in a
Saturday it was like an executive box
and stuff like that and I'm thinking my
kind and I spoke to my mum about it and
she's like you you should you know do
this and say this and go on social media
I was like you know what it's not even
worth it because the backlash that I'll
get from it will be oh what's a porn
star doing anything you know with a
child in that aspect like oh you're
sorting tickets for a child Dot and it's
just that kind of people worry mentality
and it's like you know what just keep my
mouth shut I've done my good deed the
big man upstairs will know I'm all right
in terms of the family Dynamic is your
is your missus in the industry yeah kind
of she does her own only fans page but
first and foremost she's a mum and she's
a brilliant brilliant mum like people
who think you know a porn star couple
raising children
people are you know I think oh they're
going to be exposed to this that and
whatever we're probably even stricter
with our children and going back to the
conversation with your son for example
yeah uh have you thought about how
you're going to word that no I'm not and
that's something I think me and my wife
want to sit down together and say hey
look mummy daddy do this because he does
notice already when we go to like the
football match I don't know 20 30 let's
oh can we get pictures can we you know
shout in singing a song and everything
like that I know for me I'm like oh this
is brilliant but then also I'm thinking
I've got to protect my little one you
know what I mean because I I'm very like
wary I don't want people taking pictures
of him you know posting it on social
media and and things like that like I
had it before once we were we were just
having breakfast in Vegas
and the big group of guys and you could
tell from the corner and I just take in
Sly pictures and I was like look I don't
mind it I just went I said let's I
understand you trying to take a picture
I'll have a group photo with you just
please delete the one to my little boy
because I just don't want his face out
there because I'm very worried about you
know all the parents like judging like
him not being allowed to maybe go around
to a friend's house just because oh his
parents do that or they're not allowed
to come around two hours because oh his
parents do that and and that's a big
worry a huge huge worry because
we did have one instant where we had
like a a barbecue and mums and dads had
came and I'm very low-key you know when
I go to school I hat on or just my wife
will go and one time we had a barbecue
and parents were there and they were
there to three o'clock in the morning
absolutely rip roaring drunk and all of
a sudden they've gone home and they're
texting is your husband Kieran Lee and
then my wife just put you know monkey
face emoji you know and that we've been
watching his stuff for years like oh wow
we didn't we didn't know if it was him
so
it's like that kind of then awkwardness
it's like ah okay just been having
drinks in a bar you know a burger with
these people now that you know she sat
home flicking the bean to me it's a bit
it's inescapable yeah a bit awkward
[__] helmet and the thing the thing I
think will help the situation maybe so
many people are normalizing porn yeah
that I just feel like your son's gonna
grow up in a completely different
generation where like
to get a picture of a girl who you know
with her boobs out for example yeah it's
just become like the the easiest thing
compared to when this all started online
um have you noticed a difference since
yeah it's like you said it it's a
double-edged sword because it is
becoming more accepted because look you
know during covid you had Sharon from
wherever now starting an Oni fence and
she's making you know however much a
month like there's a good example
there's a girl that's on Tick Tock Becky
Goodwin I think a big good win or
Goodwill she was single mum struggling
to get by
creating only fans now she's she's on to
buying a second house third house just
from only fans so I think it's gave like
you know some single mums maybe hope but
then I also see the girls like I'm just
really worried about if I do this I'm
never gonna find a guy and and things
like that and I my my advice is listen
live your life what you don't want to be
living your life then to be reliant on a
man you know do what makes you happy it
is tricky for them I guess because yeah
for men out there obviously you're a
very like liberal relaxed sort of
attitude and it's so nothing for you but
there are some men I think a lot of men
actually who
it would freak them out of it if they
yeah like if they if they like a girl
and they're like oh but people can buy
pictures of your tits out there like
that's a problem the possessiveness that
every man has a little bit of and all of
that alpha male into yeah it's like oh I
I've seen you on on video getting
smashed by Kieran Lee Danny D and it's
like I'm never going to be able to do
that whatever and it's you know it's a
dick Envy thing and things like that
it's I say it with girls in the industry
that you'll get in in the biz and then
all of a sudden they'll get a boyfriend
six seven months line I'm only doing
girl girl now and it's like okay you're
not taking dick on camera anymore no no
my boyfriend doesn't want me to okay
that's fine so can you tell me you know
like those early days of porn what that
was like for you
oh wow I uh how long ago was it 20 years
yeah 20 years ago and it was interesting
like my first ever seen was in a car
park a dog in car park in Derby this
company well a couple at the time like
come and meet in Derby I thought it's
the lads winding me up and uh I still
remember me shook me tracking I've gone
for a run and then all of a sudden
they're at the car park a McDonald's car
park in Derby Mark Eaton Island and like
oh yeah we're in a green Mondeo oh my
God
okay
so I've gone over how are you like that
I'm thinking I've got to do it I can't
can't back out
and uh jumped in the back of the car and
gave his condom and cracked and I'm
thinking I'm looking at my old boy and
thinking Jesus Christ I've never trimmed
that good thing in my life like because
you know back then you weren't thinking
I'm gonna trim my bollocks like a little
overgrown forest and I did brilliant and
she said they were like oh can you come
back next week I was like yeah so that
was it and then I was like living the
dream and I was like I was banging all
these MILFs and getting paid like 150
quid a time and I'm like Jesus this is
great and that was it so what was the
oldest woman you've done oh
she's got well
78.
this is this is the best one this is
actually this is actually Crimson how do
they even get wet at that age a lot of
loop a lot of lube and tears
um your tears yeah no I remember we we
kind of got I don't know if we got
tricked or not but it was in a scene in
England and I remember me and my mate
and uh we they said oh we're working
with this really hot milf I'm like okay
great so we've rocked up and I remember
driving all the way from Derby to this
shoot and we've walked through the door
this little old woman's opened the door
and let us in hello sweetheart how are
you oh yeah yeah yeah so we've gone in
and we've gone to the producer oh Mike
where where's the girl
oh you didn't see Eileen when you walked
in yeah
that's the girl and yeah yeah and I'm
thinking
yeah and um she was doing two scenes one
with me and one with my mate and we
looked at each and he goes I'm not doing
it I was like calm we've driven all this
way
and you're you're not right in the end I
said Carla let's just crack on so we
flipped the coin to see who did the
scene first
and I'll never forget this day he he
lost the the bat and he did first and he
did reverse cowgirl so she was facing
away he did spoon facing away and he did
doggy facing away and I remember he's
going at it and she's come off his dick
and she's gone to kiss him and he's gone
cut we'll have none of that wow and like
a kiss off the ground yeah yeah he's
like that and that was it and then he
finished the scene and he's come running
up the stairs and I'm in the shower he's
like move move and he started being sick
he's like oh God she's disgusting and
I've gone oh
I don't know is she gray head are we
talking yeah gray and like [__]
piercings that made it look even like a
proper set occurs it was rough but
anyway so when they're going oh it must
be really bad
so I'm thinking I've got to go I've gone
into a really dark place now I'm
thinking the most
disturbing naughty thoughts of it I'm
watching porn before and I'm like my
dick was like a lead pipe
so I've gone down I've done this scene
and I've just I've gone through it like
a train
she's like they're filming it thinking
is she gonna have a heart attack and I
remember it was all vag
and I'm doing it in last position and
all of a sudden I'm like
oh
and all I've said everyone go cut cut
look down she [__] herself
no everywhere oh dear can I get you a
baby wipe on that yeah I think we'll do
the pop shot now wow and yeah so yeah
there's a that was a bit of a grim she's
probably dead no she's probably yeah
[__] me imagine died by the [__] of
Kieran
no Jesus Christ
that is not a normal story no it's not
it's not normal at me that's a first on
this show yeah it's a bit different you
used to you know YouTubers boxes and
everything like this now you're talking
about old women [__] themselves
wow
that is [__] insane how how I wonder
how you got there mentally do you know
what I mean I can switch off I don't you
know like this and this I I did an
article years ago and it went everywhere
people think oh these this porn cassan
over he's gonna last hours in bed and
everything like that when it's
working I'm like yeah okay because I
know I have to open up for the camera I
have to make sure the lights in and all
that good stuff
when I'm at home with my misses I had
two pump trumpet and this went
everywhere last time I was like oh and I
remember it was in the sun porn
Superstar the last two seconds in bed
I'm like flop in bed I'm like great I
guess it's a bit like for a normal guy
where you know when you first meet a
girl you're really trying to make a good
impression but if you're two years into
a relationship that it varies from day
to day yeah yeah and I was assuming
that's a bit like that like on camera
you're putting pressure on yourself yeah
but you must have a really strong mind
like and and because it becomes almost
an athletic event what you're doing I
mean how much of it is sexual arousal
versus athletic performance
um I think about a lot of it is now just
knowing your body it it's like little
things is like I know what gets me hard
I know positions that I enjoy in
positions that
you know that are comfortable for me
that's going to keep my dick rock hard
and like you say you can go through a
different mindset I can really just
switch off and I'm not a lot of guys do
because all they're worried about is am
I pleasing that am I doing this and you
know in in your personal life you're
like oh am I doing a good job is she
enjoying that where with me I'm thinking
okay I've got this covered I've got that
angle yeah okay I'm good okay the girl
looks good that's that's one of the
biggest things is like you know you
maybe want to cover it something here or
you know it's not a good angle there
let's move into a different position so
you're constantly thinking it's like
tactics like the tactic board like okay
I'm not going to play with the 442 today
I'm going to pay with the back three and
go live as in like yeah you know the
go-to's yeah yeah and and like I said it
it got it's got to that stage in my
career that I know I'm comfortable with
what I'm doing I can sit in dick in hand
and talking to the crew oh yeah oh what
are you doing this weekend oh you're
doing that and like the biggest one is I
can sit and watch the football while I'm
doing a scene so if Darby's on
game over there yeah like I said I said
it before and Derby gets me hard you
know
so in terms of like because you spoke
about uh Mike meal like earlier and
obviously here I had a long relationship
with Lana Rhodes and he was telling me
like for a woman for that female
performers well I mean
you know he had a vested interest in the
situation but he's obviously spent a lot
of time with female performers as well
like how much of them do you think it's
Athletic versus uh sexual arousal like
do you think are they certain because I
feel like the girls who as a as a
watcher there's certain performers who
I'm like you really [__] love this
yeah and that's why I want to watch you
more because for me there's some girls
uh there's a girl called Adriana yeah
she she makes it like loves it yeah I'm
I'm not watching her for what her she
looks like as much as her personality of
what a [__] chicken yeah yeah yeah it
actually gets you more into it than
where if I had a girl who was like my
ideal woman you know like how much of
them do you think are just putting it on
and how much of it is real some girls
are great actresses you know in the
industry you know you can they can make
you uh like a king and it's like oh yeah
[__] me harder do this and that as soon
as that camera stops all right see ya
bye really
I thought I thought I was like a Greek
god a minute ago and now I'm just like
you know Mr Bean
no but like you said and like Mike I
think he's brilliant like you know I
felt really bad for him actually when
um he first started dating Lana because
I I would presume it's quite hard for
him coming because you know celebrity
and he's in the Limelight and I'm I'm
looking on my Twitter every day and I'm
getting him tagged in tweets with Lana
getting railed and I'm thinking he
doesn't want to see that so people were
tagging him in videos yeah okay and I
think that's sad but it's jealousy
though yeah it's jealousy and I I think
like I think he handled it brilliant I
think he really did because you don't
want to be checking you know this is
what he does for a career he's you know
social media and things like that and
checking his phone every day and all
you're seeing is your Miss is getting
railed his mental strength would have
been brewing and like you know he's
moved on from that and he moved on from
Lana and he's living the dream now the
boy well actually this this was kind of
a learning experience for a lot of
people online because of Mike's close
relationship with Logan Paul they
realized when we have Lana Rhodes in our
videos yeah the videos do [__]
unbelievable yeah crazy and and what
that proved to the new generation is
porn stars can be celebrities too yeah
and this was the first time where
from in my experience I'm you know
you've you've been in the industry a
long time where they've stepped out of
the sort of Shadows of porn where it's
like you're a big deal but in porn only
yeah yeah and now we've got girls like
Riley Reid and Lana who are becoming
influencers in their own right well that
was it and I would say I'd say the Logan
Paul podcast open the doors for a lot of
the girls in the industry especially
like Riley Riley's huge he's a she's a
superstar now and everybody knows who
she is and I think it's now becoming
like you said it's it's views people
want views so they go okay you know what
this girl gets x million views on her
videos she's got a fan base already
let's actually find out what this girl's
like without a dick in the mouth pretty
much and now they're like oh she's she's
actually really cool and then like you
say these guys get to know them
and then it starts getting a little bit
it's [__] difficult it's hard I don't
know if I can handle that yeah and
that's the thing and I think a lot of
guys are like that you know a lot of
these guys like oh I like the idea of
having a porn star girlfriend but they
don't know the baggage that comes with
it you know the constant media abuse of
dick in her ass or oh I've watched your
girlfriend you know keep typical
keyboard Warriors well I mean on the
line I think she came out and did an
interview video uh basically just
denounced the whole porn industry and
said it should be illegal I mean that
that's probably someone who's quite
scarred from all of it
um at this point I guess so I I put a
tweet at probably six seven months ago
and I'm like okay I understand you know
it's not for you now
but my big gripe is you still call
yourself Lana Rhodes
that's not your real name yeah delete
delete Lana Rhodes Persona because you
don't want to be reminded of that's such
a horrific experience daily but you've
built a brand from it now and you've
you've built a good life from it you
you're making great money from it
but if you don't want that get rid of it
I know it's it's hard to just say I'll
just get rid of your your whole brand
and everything that lead you in a
comfortable life but I don't agree with
the biggest inspiration for girls is
probably Riley Reed this girl is she's
conquered the industry for in in my eyes
she's a true porn star Lana wears a
flash in the pants she did I don't know
maybe 100 scenes if that Mia four or
five scenes either I can't even remember
how big she began yeah she blew up
because of you know wearing um the hijab
type thing and that but for me Riley
She's she started from the very bottom
in the industry worked herself up to
Megastar
made millions and millions
but still has that respect for the
industry she will never turn it back on
the industry now you know she's she's a
mum she's you know she puts it online
and she's brilliant and I think a lot of
girls should look to her and aspire to
be you know like not ashamed of what
you've done but use it as you know a
great business model like her Angela
White them girls I think are unreal I'm
a fan of Angela show up I was how was
she Angela unreal she's for me she's in
my my top three oh wow you know and it
is I love big boobs but I've always been
a fan of tits on a stick I don't know
why just always been my thing Angela's a
you know a curvier girl big boobs
man that woman makes like I've said it
before makes any man feel like a king
doesn't matter who she's working with
she knows how
to push the guy's button to make him
you know you know what I think there's
there's a thing there that even ordinary
women uh who obviously aren't pursuing a
career but there's there's a trick there
that there some of them miss out on yeah
you know because obviously my experience
is with ordinary women and you know and
it's not that they
you know what a lot of women get
criticized for being like laying there
yeah because they don't have the
confidence yeah but with that confidence
when a woman knows how to unlock a man
the way that these women can they just
have them wrap around their little
finger that's it yeah and that is like
Angela but in a good way yeah I've never
seen the girl take advantage in any
situation the guys having a rough day
she will she will turn that day around
and turn it from a rough day into a
sunshine day but that's an interesting
point though about taking advantage
because these women have some men kind
of obsessed with them have you seen
women who've like you know because
there's this new thing where women are
taking money off guys blackmailing them
and all this weird Financial domination
yeah I've seen I've seen a lot of guys
there's um there's a lot of fetishes for
it where guys really enjoy being
financially dominated like here's my
wife's email address
threaten threaten me and I'll send you
ten thousand dollars and I'm going
that's unheard of yeah I'd never do that
what about like stalkers do you think a
lot of them have stalkers yeah I think
girls and guys like for me that's why
obviously you have stage names and
things like that but I've I've rocked up
one time with like signed photos in you
know in your mailbox and I'm going what
what is that like have they got my
address and please send this back you
know here's a a sealed envelope you know
prepaid envelope please sign this and
I'm like and then like you say you have
a look at like conventions like the avns
and things it's huge the cure for your
autographs yeah yeah and it's you have
thousands of people coming from All Over
America some all over the world to meet
their favorite porn star but these guys
uh come in with
books and I mean like DVD copies
pictures lingerie please sign this
please sign that they know the girl's
whole career from her very first scene
like I've had guys come to me going oh I
can remember when you did that scene
with Adriana chechik and I'm going
uh yeah which one I know he's like oh
this one she was wearing a blue bikini
and you had such an I'm thinking that's
his favorite yeah and I'm thinking I
struggled to remember what I had for
dinner yesterday and you you're telling
me what scene
these people freak me out a bit because
like for them it becomes an obsession
yeah that's that's the big one and
that's when you have to really worry
about they they take that Obsession into
the real world and that for me like you
say in the porn porn side of things it's
like one thing I want to start to get
into right especially in the next like
this year is educating you know
especially males like you know the
university guys like hey guys yeah you
might see me not wearing a condom in a
scene I get tested every 10 days get
yourself checked up you know what you
see in a scene where you know a lady's
getting choked or slapped or harassed
you know that was very American when it
asks her ass spanked these girls we go
through a big you know list before of
your do's and don'ts and we have like a
female liaison on set that is stating
okay the good it's for the girls you
know safety at all time whenever you
feel uncomfortable with any part of the
scene like your liaison though and we
make it so it's all about the woman and
that's a big thing now but I want
especially like I said going forward I
want like to educate guys younger male
guys now that I'm getting a bit older
like hey guys come on yeah I think
that's a really good point because from
what I understand at universities as you
mentioned that's where
ah it seems like sexual assaults and
stuff like that all right yeah because
these young Lads they're full of
testosterone with not a [__] clue
what they're doing they're watching a
lot of porn playing PlayStation and
they're just like oh yes this is how
we're done and it is totally not like
that and it's like you're thinking
they're going out on a Friday Saturday
night a hammer drunk beer dog girl might
you know make a you know give a bit of
fingers or whatever and then next week
you know and they're like oh well I'm
gonna push it as far as I can possibly
go and that's when you've got to get
that consent well and yeah that's where
you've got to educate guys like Hey
listen if it goes pushing you away in
that back off well it's not just the the
thing that I've heard the most common
story that I've heard from that
situation is like when women are at Uni
and they're drunk themselves and they
kind of realize what's happening and
then they say no yeah mid-act and the
men don't stop yeah there was unilads
they're just like going wild animals and
that's it and then also you've got to
think as well these a lot of these guys
aren't bagging up yep and that's when
you start going okay
got chlamydia from this guy and it's
like hang on you don't need to go like
you say get a checkup just you know how
often do you have outbreaks in the
industry
um you know what not really very often I
think in the hot I've been in it 20
coming up to 21 years and we had one HIV
shutdown and that was just as a
precaution like it's very rare that you
get like chlamydia gonorrhea and things
like that in the industry just because
the girl on a you know a Friday night
that works in the porn industry isn't
going to go out sleep with anyone
because if she ends up catching
something gets a bad test she's out of
work for let's say seven to ten days
that's a lot of money she's gonna lose
so she's going it's not worth it hold on
look at the porn industry in such a way
where it's like mechanical and like a
functioning industry we are and I think
the pre the preconception that a lot of
people have is these girls are
fatherless drug addicts yeah and it's
just that's the stigma yeah how far away
is that from so far away from you it's
crazy because obviously everybody's
growing up in it they think oh Boogie
Nights it's filled with drugs and mad
orgies and things like that and I'm like
I wish nothing like that and I think
it's nothing like that at all it's like
like a good example is like maybe five
six years ago we did a Christmas dinner
and we invited Maybe
10 12 Pawn people and we they're all
like European performers living in the
UK yeah uh in L.A and we've done a big
Christmas photo and like we're all
wearing silly onesies Christmas jumper
you know trying things like that and we
posted it online and everybody oh you
must have had an orgy what did you do
naked twister and things like that I'm
thinking
no we we had dinner
then we add like cheese in there and
everyone got super fat and then we
played like Monopoly and stupid board
games like everybody else does just
because you do porn is not you're not
thinking sex XXX all day every day but
then you do shark every day yeah
um pretty much yeah and how do you keep
that going because you're getting older
yeah I've had gray hair since I was 30
but no
um no I don't know for me I could you
could probably say yeah I have a I have
an addiction to it but it's a controlled
addiction and I use that addiction for
my work so it's a healthy addiction
right you could say Well it it is
because you've found the perfect
industry for you to be in yeah but if
like if you ever had to have a break
from porn for whatever reason oh it did
if you think about it we had uh
coronavirus so we we shut down for eight
months nine months or whatever it was
you must have been going up the wall I
wasn't my wife was because she was I
can't wait for you to go back to work
because I'm there going you know babe
babe mummy daddy time not tonight no
like you know I'm thinking every night
she's like I can't handle it you know
she's she's quite content yeah are you
aware of a guy called Stephen bear
he's an only fans guy who used to be on
reality TV yep oh and I yeah a real
piece of work yes he he had this girl
uploaded it without her consent uh the
video where they were having sex she's
then taken up the court he's now
um he's now gone to prison yeah I just
wondered what you make of that whole
scenario as someone in the industry I'm
with you scumbag yeah like I've had the
I've had the situation happen before to
my with myself where I've shot a scene
with a girl and we've exchanged you
because we always do the model release
forms two two five sevens and things
like that and this was a girl brand new
to the industry she was like an
Instagram girl we shot a scene and she's
gone let's release it blah blah blah
okay great and then maybe about a week
or so before we went to release it she's
turned around and said I've had second
thoughts I don't want to release it okay
fine no problem I just delete the scene
because for me I don't want to take that
chance of ruining this girl's life
because once he's out there on the net
is out there and you know you there's
got to be that's another form of consent
you know it's all well and good you
might have done the deed but then if
you're going to get into this posting it
on platforms you've got to have that
consent of hey yeah you're okay to post
it am I okay to post it what date do you
want to post it how much do you want to
post it and things like that so for this
guy to do it I don't know I don't know
enough about it but all I know is like
you said he's just posted it made a bit
and probably made what two three grand
from it it was literally that yeah and
it's like what I was doing 21 months in
jail yeah and and now he's his life's
ruined because he's going to come out
and you know
I don't know I I I was also looking into
one shocking story which is the Ron
Jeremy story yeah yeah fascinating thing
um because when I was first getting into
a porn as a kid like teenage boys he's
an idol he was like a huge yeah yeah and
he was saying he was one of the first
porn stars who was in music videos and
yeah like Snoop Dogg and all them with
the [__] arms around him and recently
uh for those who don't know this is like
a guy who'd been in for decades is now
uh gone to jail he's been reported for
uh rape uh you know I saw all of these
things and he's like 70 years old and
he's just a little yeah now in there
from what I understand is I think it's
getting dropped because they're saying
he's not mentally stable to proceed with
the trial but you quote me on that one
but again a lot of the the actions that
happened with the from what like the
rape things was offset really not on set
from like again not that I know of onset
but a lot of the stories that I read was
like in the rainbow room and and places
like that in LA
which was on normal Friday Saturday
night and I'm not condemning it but
that's not on a pawn set because on a
porn set
you have maybe 10 15 crew members and a
lot of times people are stopping and go
hey hang on a minute you're not doing
that that's out of order do you think
that's become like that because of the
way things used to be yeah I think I
think that wasn't like the wild west at
one point in your lifetime no I've never
seen it and that's the funny thing you
know I've seen you know hardly anything
ever like that and that's that's one of
my big frustrations because people think
it must be like that on set and you know
I could see it being very intimidating
for a girl because you know especially
what we've done now like I said we
bought in the liaison because it's a
very heavy dominated industry by men so
if you're turning up to that you may
just only have the female makeup artist
but then the camera guy you know two or
three camera guys all men lighting guys
men sound guys men catering men
so you might not have many females on
set so I could see it being very
intimidating pretty cool so that's why
browsers as a company said hey you know
what let's have somebody there for the
girl at all times if she wants a water
if she wants a baby wiper straw whatever
she might want she has a point of
contact the whole time and it's been
brilliant I think it's been a breath of
fresh air in the industry for sure no
wonder you had so much of a problem with
the Lana Rhodes Court then because yeah
your account and her account are
completely completely different I did I
think a second or third scene and you
know I when she said that I hated the
industry I was like I find that quite
hard to believe because I had her on set
many a times and she was brilliant she
was an amazing amazing performer I'll
never knock that maybe she had bad
experience on other sets for sure but
everybody has bad days at the office you
know it could be the guy that she's
working with that day the girl that she
maybe was working with that day so yeah
she probably has had bad experiences
like we all have but I don't think it's
as bad as she probably made out as you
know I hated every single minute of it I
think when women got [__] shamed as well
yeah that's it I wanted to denounce it
yeah completely and like I said she's a
mother now yeah so she probably he
doesn't want that you know that shaming
which is again it's horrible for her to
have to go through and obviously a
child's probably gonna have to go for it
as well the same is mine you know they
they're going to have to go through that
traumatic experience but all we can do
is parents is be there how many times
have you seen fathers that you know
doctors lawyers teachers whatever they
are they've they're married and they
just leave their kids I don't know if
it's a misogynist thought for me to have
this but I kind of feel like
it's it's different having a father
versus a mother in the porn industry I
don't know why maybe that's because I'm
a man you're 100 right because
you think if you if you're a lad and
you're going to school oh look here's a
picture how many times did you say mum
jokes when you were young exactly it's
like a sore point in it yeah and it's
like you can really dig it people and I
can see it may be a bit easy for my life
like oh your dad's had sex with all
these beautiful women yeah yeah it's a
bit of a flexing yeah listen yeah I've
got a bigger dick than my dad you know
what I mean so maybe like Arlene sure is
for two million
um but because he's gonna be like my
dad's forgotten the names of all these
yeah yeah I've never even had them yeah
exactly yeah hang on I think my dad
might know your man
um but so I can see that that's gonna it
must be hard for it and maybe she you
know deep down that's where she has a
resentment from
I don't know but we all go through
different Journeys one of the one of the
big stories that's come out recently all
over Twitter I don't know if you've seen
it it's the PornHub Scandal now this is
kind of a thing that's been going on
where people have been uploading content
of like young people on PornHub and
making money from it and then PornHub
are sort of
kind of distancing themselves and now
they're coming under Fire from it yeah I
think from what I understand they came
Under Fire a hell of a lot for it but if
you go back and look at all the
statistics on it
any numbers compared to Facebook
Instagram Twitter I think I think I was
actually terrible for it well they had
they had more than PornHub and any any
porn site so for me I think it's very
harsh that PornHub were being held up as
the time it's like hey that's that
they're they're the scumbags they're the
one where with porno you have to now I
know obviously first time because I
upload my content there is
you have to send in your model release
forms with
consent the date of birth your passport
and everything like that so you can't
upload whereas Twitter you can upload
anything anybody can go oh I'm going to
create a Facebook account here you go
I'm going to upload bestiality or I'm
going to upload whatever so for me again
it's it's a bit a big gripe where porn
is the the the target of pedophilia and
things like that where I'm going oh hang
on a minute can we look at the biggest
social media platforms and they are the
biggest culprits in my house wow yeah
I've never really thought about that
that's a great point because
um you I think those you know you're
more familiar with America than I am how
people get they kind of just want to use
a stick to beat the pollen companies
with I guess yeah and that's the thing
and it's it's a frustrating one where
you just sometimes you just wish to be
left alone we're in our own little world
we're not doing home we're you know
we're creating content which globally
people enjoy
and and that's where it gets really
frustrated and it gets really
like you say very frustrating in terms
of like hey let's look at the big
companies because that's where the
problem is really really basically and
let's be honest if you're an 8 to 12
year old kid
you're not probably going on porn up you
you first your your first access to
social media platforms is going to be
Twitter Facebook Snapchat things like
that tick tock
it's not PornHub you're not going if
you're going to Pornhub you're looking
for porn
where you could be a miner just
scrolling through and all of a sudden
what's that there's no regulations on it
and that's that's like I said that's a
big BMI Bonnet about it I was like let's
look that way first before we we came
the porn industry in terms of an
averagely successful female performer
what rough kind of money would a girl
like that make now I know girls earn in
anywhere between 700 to a mil a month on
the in the industry I know
I don't want to say average girls but
you know girls that don't have like the
profiles of urangulas and Riley Reid
still making anywhere between 25 to 40
000 a month
um I know stay home mums that are
earning
40 to 50 000 a month you know selling
pictures of their toenails and then
things like that which is crazy which
for me I think as well these platforms
have been brilliant in terms of helping
some girls get off the streets
in terms of you know I've known girls
that maybe were doing escorting in the
past and this platform is now opened up
where hey I don't have to do that I can
make my money by doing solo content and
things like that and it saved so many
girls especially you know mentally
mentally it's been brilliant in terms of
the escort and thing I always wondered
like
you know these girls are having sex on
camera
and I'm sure that they have these big
money guys approaching them yeah how how
often do you think that happens well it
was very common back in the day not so
much now because like you say these
girls can make
hundreds of thousands of dollars by
doing a homemade video with their
boyfriend where let's be real it's like
a footballer if you get put a contract
in front of you to go from Sunderland to
Newcastle and they're going we're going
to pay you x amount more you're going to
take it on you I love the analogy yeah
yeah but yeah so that's the thing
sometimes these girls are going look I'm
getting offered x amount of dollars to
do an escort job with it could be
a Brad Pitt look-alike it's just you
know a wealthy businessman that goes
I've got a fascination with this girl I
want to see her you recently mentioned
in a podcast that you had some
frustrations with how porn is becoming
uh
I guess racially motivated and and you
mentioned like how people are getting
paid differently depending on uh doing
scenes uh that are interracial for
example yeah that was one of my big pet
peeves when I came to America
um I I never understood it because
working in the UK
you could be
a ex-girl going to work and doing a
scene with a black performer it might be
the first time you've ever
been with the black guy and things like
that but you never paid any more you
were never paid any more or anything it
was just a scene where when I went to
America that was a big shock to me
because it was like oh it's an
interracial scene
yeah okay well I charge more for
interracial I'm like well why
I'm like oh well you know the guy's got
a big dick I'm going hang on I'm Pretty
Fly for a White Guy myself you know I've
got a big old boy probably bigger than
and it was the excuses and it used to
really wind me up and it still does to
to this day and to be honest now you
don't really hear of that anymore it's
kind of died off thankfully
um just because I can for me you know
we all bleed [__] the same you cut me
open you cut lexicon steel open we all
bleed Claret you're uh and you're
getting into directing as well right
getting I've done it for oh
11. wow
so a majority of the scenes that I
perform in for browsers now I direct
okay and so you're charging twice for
that yeah our charger producers rate as
well so yeah but I love that because I'm
a nightmare because sometimes the
director I want you to do this position
in that position I'm like
no I just want to do it my way so now I
don't really shoot for any of the other
producers just because I am a princess
on set I am that's my nickname princess
that's so funny yeah that's just because
I'm like I'm not doing that because
because I'm a bit of a um like I'm a
perfectionist with what I do and I can
only imagine like what is it like for
you when you're trying to build a scene
in your head do you do you have like
almost like a mood board visually or do
you have certain camera angles that
you're going for that or the the shots
that the fans want to see are you well
aware of that looks good so for me when
I perform and back in the day I used to
want to please everybody
and I'd be like right I have to get this
position in that position now where now
what I I do is I use the Stills as a
blueprint so we always do sex Stills
before the actual video
so that for me I can go okay you know
what this is a good position I can
really open up here you know what this
is a comfy position here what does open
up mean open up to the camera so if
you're doing doggy at home you're not
just going straight on sorry if you're
doing doggy um you're going straight on
where with me I'm yoga hip out yeah
because you kind of dog you have to kind
of bend your body to the side so that
the camera can get the angle right that
must be [__] tricky man yeah it is
but and then you you're not like is it
like you're not going like that you're
going bending It Like Beckham you know I
mean you're swinging it in every angle
and then you're like okay great so the
camera guy can say you you'll be
sometimes in a scene where you'll be
going out and the camera guy might not
see and he'll tap your leg or like pull
your leg open so they can see everything
going in but thankfully like I said over
the years I I know all my angles and you
know I'm like a free kick master that is
that's well drilled yeah just put it in
the top bins
um but no so that was it but I like to
say I'd like to use the The Stills to
get my get the map of where I'm going to
go in the scene and then also it might
be in the scene where I'm going wow this
is my dick's like a lip you know what
let's pull out some tricks let's do a
few step overs and I'll be lifting her
up I'll be spinning her around and and
things like that but if you're not 100
in a scene if you're not like you know
110 rock hard you'd be going oh you know
what I might not try that because you
might go down in the scene and then it's
up there because then it's like okay cut
because all of a sudden you've got
everybody watching you and you pull in a
bit of string
eyes are on you like people are like
looking at the phone looking at the
watch you know playing Angry Birds and
you're like give us a shout when you're
ready
it's just the pressure pressure yeah
that's it like a hurricane penalty and
sometimes like you say sometimes the
girl will be like oh do you want me to
tickle your balls do you want me or
whatever sometimes like if you've got
Angela
Angela will be should lick your bum like
a stamp yeah but then sometimes your
girl will be like okay right she'll just
get up she'll go get a water she'll go
get a makeup touched up again and we all
assume that you guys are chewing Viagra
every single so you can't it that's a
big myth as well everywhere oh you can
take a Viagra and you're going to be
rock hard if you don't have that
chemistry up there down there is not
going to work
[Music]
I feel like I'm getting a boxing coach
well you know if your feet are wrong
yeah I mean there's all little tips okay
so because guys used to inject the
addiction yeah I've seen that and that's
a bit
yeah not for me I I squint when I uh I
have to get my blood drawn every 10 days
I'm like yeah so I don't want a needle
going anywhere near my old boy but
there's all like little tricks it's like
for example if your feet are cold
put your socks on because your dick's
not going to get hard
because if your feet are cold where does
the blood rush to right exactly yeah
it's gonna bypass you did go see you
later mate there's a cold bit down there
and I'll warm them up first okay there's
a lot of chat about the impact of porn
on men and I wanted to talk to you about
that because obviously like you say the
unilads are watching it yeah yeah and uh
there's a lot of people who think men
expect too much from a woman in the
bedroom like regular girls now
um are kind of expected to to
basically these guys are looking at porn
and they're
pressurizing The Guild to perform Like a
Porn that's that's not how it should be
it's it's a communication thing how do
you enjoy do you like this do you like
that talk to you talk to your your
partner and things like that you've got
to remember look look at you know
mainstream movies it's an act same as
the porn industry it is an act and it
I'm not trying to kill the fantasy
because you know sometimes you do have
great chemistry on set and the scene is
a genuine raw lust you know brilliant
sexual chemistry but sometimes you can
look at a scene and go I've done it many
times when I've walked away from a
ceiling guy God that was awful what a
bad scene really and then I've seen
people online go wow the chemistry you
two had was out of this world I'm
thinking are they all about the same
scene one of the things I was thinking
about was women who sort of have to then
leave porn and go back to normal life
and what that must be like are you aware
of like struggles yeah yeah I've seen
many girls I've seen girls that were
doing porn uh studying to be a lawyer
you know Paul was paying the bills you
know and then she's she's worked so hard
she's completed everything all her exams
she's now a qualified lawyer trying to
get a job after that
Mission Impossible
and it's like you know this girl's come
from maybe you know
and not a very well you know solid
parents but not you know a financial
backing to to go to university and
things like that and she's maybe not to
you know you could say maybe not chose
the right way but she's she's turned
upon because it's a good way to make a
lot of money fast and she's done that on
camera and off camera she's worked her
tits off
to get where she wants to be and goal
her end goal was to be a lawyer she's
got there she's debt free but now she
can't get a job because of
her past and it's sad yeah that is tough
and when when you're sort of you know
like you're selecting these girls who
are just coming into the industry what
are you looking for in terms of
um them as a performer when you're
hiring them as a director and the girls
don't normally get to the browser stage
until they've done basically worked the
ways up the lower leagues and work you
know with some of the smaller sites and
going wow she really stands out she's
she's a player yeah and then she that's
when she becomes on like you know the
browsers and things like that one of the
one of the things about your life that
really was interesting
was your relationship with your dad yeah
do you mind talking about that no no
an emotional thing where I was like I'm
quite surprised that you know I'm
watching this porn interview and I'm
hearing you talk about your father and
I'm like [__] me yeah this is brutal
like for me I grew up and I was again
super super close with my old man like
you know football you know that was our
life my football manager I'd go to
football with him I'd go to watch him
play football you know nine like I want
to say four to five times a week I was
with my old man and you know you for me
that was my idol and then again he has a
brilliant job and you know he ended up
having an affair left the family home
and for me I'm very stubborn in that and
so we didn't really speak after that how
old were you in that I'd have been 10
okay at a time but then I was like okay
great and and that was it and that was a
chapter closed in my life after that and
I think now looking back at it yeah
it's probably one of the best things
that could ever happen because I look at
it and go I would have never gone into
porn I would have stayed at the railway
I'd have never met my wife I'd have
never had free brilliant children
and it's also taught me a lesson as a
parent there's no way cat in Hell's
chance you'll ever see me turn my back
on my kids and I I make sure I'm there
for them 24 7. whatever they want to do
like for me I wanted I was desperate for
my boy to play football
I don't want to do it that okay no
problem never going to push him into
something he didn't want to do
now he's obviously he's into his
football and he loves it and I'm like
this is amazing
um but now it's taught me a lot of
things that how I want to parent in the
future and one of them is never never
turn my back on my kids and I was I was
lucky listen I had a mum that did the
role of both
amazing and that's why now as I live in
Los Angeles I speak to my mum two three
times a day
my sister lives 10 minutes down the road
I'll be oh you're supposed to resistor
I've not spoke to her this week do you
know what I mean I mean it's crazy but
that's you know again that goes back to
me where I have such a huge respect for
women which is crazy to think you know
when when you see the profession that I
do
what my respect for women is
meanwhile women are getting the most
money yeah they get paid more they they
pull the shots if put it this way so if
a girl a girl can have a no list of
performance she doesn't want to work
with so if you were booked with let's
say for example I was booked with Angela
White but Angela White didn't want to
work with me
I'm the one getting replaced not Angela
White so again the women have like the
the top trump card
in the industry it's ironic that it's
arguably the industry where women are
most in charge and yet people look at it
the other one yeah but I I agree with it
you know I in the girls put themselves
through a lot you know they get a lot of
wear and tear on the body
you know literally a lot of Maintenance
you know like they have to they want to
look good and and feel good on camera
so you know they're exercising diet and
things like that so they're training
like a top level athlete all the time
really you think about it it's [__]
funny to say about this yeah and that's
why I have a massive respect for the
girls because I'm like yeah you deserve
to get paid x amount of dollars because
you see those Legends of porn don't you
think those women who've just been at it
for [__] decades years and you know
what I feel bad for some of them girls
because they kind of maybe have missed
the gravy train a little bit now because
let's say I don't know maybe let's say
probably the biggest name of Jenna
Jameson yeah she she made loads back in
the day but I just think to myself if
she was in her Peak now
could you imagine what she'd be earning
now it's funny you talk about football
it's like those footballers you can't
even imagine what if he was around now
yeah look at look at Georgie best you
know what I mean yeah she's she's the
George bastard yeah yeah she's the
George a little bit she's kind of
there's there's quite a lot of those
like sad stories where like I don't know
if Jenna Jameson is clusters that but
like there's some of them who are like
it's just it's sort of that's where porn
gets its bad name I think yeah but I
think as well back then to you know be
with a porn star was a especially in
like rock and roll like it's like oh wow
and I think maybe the girls maybe got
LED down the the wrong path by the
mainstream side of things have you had
interactions with people who do like gay
and trans and that sort of stuff yeah
again back in the day it was really
taboo
um you had a lot of girls
that wouldn't work with guys that didn't
gay porn and also you had a lot of girls
that would never go anywhere near a
trans performer and over the last four
to five years it's been a massive swing
and now it's like yep I work with this
guy even though he does gay porn no
problem
I do transcene huge seller on some of
the girl site and I'm all for it you
know what I mean good on you like
whatever floats your boat do what you're
comfortable with
um and I've seen guys that were
straight so to speak and like oh they
had to put on this big like doing it oh
yeah I'm a straight guy now they're
doing scenes with trans girls and
they're perfectly happy and they're like
you know what I love the sexual Freedom
that I can have now because it's not so
you know in the closet like oh it's very
taboo and you know what fair play to it
like for me it's not my cup of tea
um I don't think I'd ever go down that
route you've never done with the Trans
no nothing and I don't think I would
because for me it's not something that
again it's all in your head
and for me yes you're working with the
Trans but there's a lot there's a lot of
what I want to say like a lot of
unordering things cracking on it's like
hang on
I'm programmed this mindset of do this
do that all of a sudden you throw in
other things into the park and it's like
oh hang on uh I don't know but yeah like
I said it's just it's just not like I
suppose for men or who are trying to
maybe go down the only fans route doing
stuff that would please a male gave me
an audience I guess they're going to
lean into that and get as much money as
they can yeah yeah yeah I've seen a lot
of guys do that and I and I think you
know what mate fair play to you you
you're trying to earn a living
crack on and you know what if you're
comfortable doing it do it I've never
been a big believer in the whole gay for
paid don't do something that you're not
happy with because you are gonna go you
are gonna be Alana Rose down the line
where you regret it and you have these
built up you know emotions like oh I
disgust me I hate this and I hate that
for me I've always done scenes that I've
enjoyed you know and I I I can genuinely
say I don't look back on my porn career
with any regrets
I like that I mean before we wrap this
up a lot of people will be wondering
extreme experiences that you've had is
there anything where you're just like
you look back at them and they stand out
as like the most crazy days aside from
the little old lady who you are a little
old lady
um I would say my first directing gig
for Brazos because I've always been the
Joker I you know I play pranks on set
all day every day and I was like let me
direct and they're like no you mess
around too much I was like right okay
what can I do to show that I'm not so I
I was like right I'm gonna do my own
scene I'm going to direct it I'm going
to pay for it and send it in and I
called it office foreplay and it was me
and four girls and I did like a comedy
sketch on it and it was brilliant and I
sent that one in and then it just that
was my it snowballed from that person
like wow this is really good and I I did
a whole series around that Lana was
Rhodes but I actually did Lorna Rhodes
Riley Reid Janice Griffin and Adra fox
in one scene and that was like the the
best scene ever
um but then also there was another scene
that I did in the UK and it was it was
me and another guy with 15 girls
and the guy next to me I'm like you know
Louis Hamilton at the start I'm like go
on go and say action and this poor
ladies literally just he looked at it it
looked like a frightened Slug
and he's his head's gone his head's gone
and you could tell he's he's popped
Viagra beetroot red and he's I can't do
it I was like what and he's like yeah
and he just he dipped oh no and then the
director's gone well do you think you
can do the seed on your own I of course
me
course and I literally went through all
I was like you know you remember
supermarkets three
no deal with him no Dale wintered on
this one but I had a bit of an orange
tan
um but yeah I just I went through all 15
so that was like yeah well they're all
bending over and you're just one after
the other yeah it was a medieval table
like this
all legs there you go all all in uh and
medieval like Game of Thrones type stuff
kind of yeah and all the girls would
just lay on the back
you know I'm like I'm living the dream
here how how tired are you after are you
like I'm [__] are you I can be
knackered yeah but it's like I said now
I plan a lot of my scenes around like
the footy I still listening and I still
play like back home and I'm I'm playing
I play
three times a week I'll leave you with
one question because I like to ask
everybody this how would you like to be
remembered
there's a derby Legend
simple I really like that that is a
[__] belt all right son uh what a
chat that was and definitely not the
norm for the true Geordie podcast but I
really enjoyed it thank you accurately
uh you could follow him he is everywhere
all over Instagram a lot and I'm sure
you'll be putting a great content ah
okay I'll keep playing away mate how
many years you got left
performing at the top level I'm like
Ronaldo till I get transferred out to uh
all right cheers and don't forget to
stay subscribe to the true Jordan
YouTube channel we'll see us on the next
one thanks magic thank you so much mate
that was brilliant loved it